[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui laurent baffie qui est avec nous il
au soir
un grand bravo à la chorale des
ménopause et huawei est massive elle est
comme une faute sur toi sami yen s en
branle maison et mon fils
il est comme un ouf sur toi ouais
s'appelle lino et toi le mien aussi les
no line aussi des jetons fils j'ai un
compte de il est en pré retraite
oui après retrait presse comme ils
s'appellent il s'appelle benjamin van
giàu l'endroit je les dix rencontres et
bénisse et un amour en plus et bastien
et benjamin basse et en vous embrassant
une femme fait nos adieux bon jérémy
c'est qu'ils s'en font du bien tu as
quatre enfants trois quatre enfants et
doux avec une [ __ ]
heureusement qu'on s'aime bien on
m'avait caché la présence de laurent je
commence à croire mais on a assez bien
commun sous la forme d'un film réalisé
par laurent qui a battu tous les records
de vente et on est dans le foot les
scieries dans un instant on va jouer sur
laurent baffie en page web
[Applaudissements]
le centre balances ton pote tu veux
faire un tube plus que ma mère ouais
alors messieurs
avant de chanter on va faire un petit
prix de la tomate en perdre alliés alors
on a le numéro de ma mère c'est parti à
l'ifa tu pue du cul c'est toi qui lui
faut c'est moi ouais les deux mois si je
peux le faire moi elle va me défoncer
mais ça peut être drôle si tu préfères
la défoncer attention deuxième info
deuxième info les chiens turbo et du
muguet a donné l'info alors oui le
muguet a mis le turbo
vous avez compris le jeu il faut je
rappelle je vous dis aux photos chez
vous aussi mais chéri vous devez trouver
l'info correspondante oui
chappatte à des nuggets sur la [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dominique chapatte que nos bras ce qui
s'est passé
la jeune scout tube est hester oui ça va
ma petite poulette tu pue du cul
[Applaudissements]
toi tu peux plus du cul esther tu peux
du tu te dis que toi même tu pue du cul
hester
[Applaudissements]
isabelle et qu'edf promène sur la plage
les abel fr regarde un oiseau mort et
qu'elle ait fait ça parce que c'est un
numéro qui est un numéro j'ai
l'impression de stars à halo on sait pas
c'est peut-être c'est connu c'est
peut-être lui qui m'appellent
non mais je vous dis parce que c'est un
numéro genre un peu un pendant voyez que
ce numéro de stores qui la retenir je
suis numéro soit ton chèque c'est sarah
et rentrer dans l'appartement une blague
l'uimm
oui rentrer dans la bataille aura sur le
plateau qui se dessine maintenant
regarde le picasso y voit une tache sur
le picasso et se rapprochent picasso est
rayé ya marqué ça et comprend pas on
regarde le renoir en face à une tâche
renoir est rayé ya marqué saravah dans
le bureau et regarde le van gogh vincent
mallet ya marqué sahara fait david david
question avec les tableaux fais ta
gueule j'ai un contrôle fiscal
j'ai tout mieux tomber
[Applaudissements]
nelson bay plutôt des émissions les
animateurs j'aimerais c'est quoi vachon
et toutes ces émissions là le type
eurovision télé réalité tu sais ça
voudra sourire je suis pas très fan et
toi lolo à moi je peux plus voir ta
gueule je décorais juste après une
petite encore avant qu'on fasse le pape
qui est malade
1 1 il est malade alors les évêques qui
s'angoissent il appelle les toubibs il
trouvera rien il l'emmène à l'hosto
effet une batterie d'examens et trouve
rien et puis la santé décline de jour en
jour il ya un évêque fait les mecs
personne connaît un médecin un peu
parallèle un rebouteux je sais pas il ya
un échec si moi je connais un type qui
est bien il ya du compteur il est
mentaliste où ça il a des résultats ils
font venir le mec il ausculte le pape
pendant deux heures et des jeunes
solution il faudrait qu'ils baisent
regardons les cellules du foie mais ça
va passer les papilles way frais qui se
vident les couilles papale saluer
remettre les méridiens ça ouvrira les
chaque race alors l'énergie reviendrai
mais bon on peut pas laisser crever
d'accord on le fait mais le chef des
évêques fait à trois conditions la [ __ ]
faut qu'elle soit aveugle faut qu'elle
soit muette et surtout qu'elle était
très gros nichons
il ya un évêque fait pourquoi des très
gros nichons l'autre et parce qu'il
adore ça
[Applaudissements]